[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum if he if your figure
there you're watching someone go crazy
it's starting to lose that mind a little
bit no I woke up late this is a real
boring story but I got a new mouth guard
night guard for my mouth my teeth you
know I grind especially nowadays I'm a
grinder but I got a new one fitted and
it was kind of like not tight like the
other one and I woke up man my jaw
doesn't hurt I feel like my next better
did you imagine if I've gone through all
this [ __ ] for the last five years it was
all because my night guard was too tight
a embarrassing be embarrassing see hey
any kind of relief I want to thank
everybody for listening the show
continued support I want to thank my
patrons who the patrons are awesome I
say at every episode but you know they
they really kick ass and they go above
and beyond subscribing is unbelievable I
appreciate everybody who subscribes and
listens and gives the podcast a chance
and follows us and all our handles or
social handles at inside a podcast I
think on Instagram Facebook and at
instanceid pod on Twitter follow us
subscribe on V Michael Rosenbaum on
Instagram give me some support I'm
always support him doing some funny
stuff on well some people think it's
funny
on Instagram some fun videos they do
Instagram lives you never know who's
gonna cut be my guest I like to talk to
people I like to invite people on the
Instagram lives the patreon I do YouTube
lives all that stuff and of course left
on Laurel my music the band's music is
available everywhere free or if you
really want to pay for you good iTunes
but why would you do that I mean you
know it's cool I am waiting for someone
a surprise guest
all right here he is folks he's uh Zooma
zoom-zoom II me should I admit him boom
dude so grant gustin's on the podcast as
you know you know we of course talked a
little bit about you we talked about
your bandanas we talked about I think
about you know your good looks we talked
about you know you take a shirt off you
know he's very humble he's a sweet guy
did you what what did you get out of
working with him what did you it's the
one thing you take it like grant I'll
always remember this about grant
it's gotta be intimidating man because
I'm doing this table reading and he's
coming in playing the flash and it's his
episode and he comes in and he [ __ ]
nails it in the table read I didn't even
need to see what he was gonna do on set
in the table read I knew oh my god they
made the right decision and then it was
just really cool on a yearly basis aside
from you know aside from the two of us
becoming friends aside from us enjoy
working together aside from us both
being able to be very honest with one
another
we have that ability just not super
common it was really nice just going to
his show once or twice a year
it's like a change of pace it was nice
and the catering wasn't I love you more
than any when you come back maybe every
couple of weeks or whatever just check
in for a morning read all right well I
miss you buddy and I give the family a
hug and I can't wait to hug you see you
buddy inside of you is brought to you by
Sun basket boy do I need these guys
right now right now some basket is
offering $35 off your order
when you go right now to son basket
dot-com slash IOU and enter promo code
IOU
at checkout so without further ado stick
around afterwards and please subscribe
to the podcast and if you have it if
you're a grant fan I know your grant fan
you're here for grant I love it
but you know give the podcast a chance I
think you'll learn something even if you
don't know all the gifts I have I
appreciate your support and I hope you
enjoy this let's get inside of Grant
Gustin it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
now I [ __ ] it up it's Gustin isn't it
yeah how many people call you goostin
really did you hate it when people mess
up mispronounced your name coach always
called me gusta and like that's all he
called common ground you just caught me
good stuff
Houston let's have a little more hustle
over here yeah and that wasn't great
were you good athlete I was pretty good
at baseball but like I I rot eclis hated
soccer because of the running I thought
it was just ridiculous to run back and
forth and hope for the ball so I quit
most sports other than baseball and toes
14:15 I stopped baseball I was like all
theater I mean you're Barry Allen you're
the flash so you're gotta be athletic
you got to run you got to look good
running there's a lot of people that
don't look good when they run my mother
is one of them this is true yeah no I I
danced for years and years and years I
guess that wouldn't necessarily help
with running but like I'm pretty aware
of my body and I'm a pretty I'm a pretty
decent looking runner you are you know
how to run you know the stride
yeah why they also actually before the
pilot I can remember his name I was
working with this like Olympic track and
field sprint coach that did that Coast
Olympians and running backs in the NFL
and and he helped me with my gait and
like kind of what my arms were supposed
to be doing with my leg so I did have
some technical training now there's a
thing where you know for instance when
when Tom Welling on Smallville had to
you know fly I mean he didn't really fly
but you know SuperSpeed or whatever he
did there's a certain look like if he
went with his gut it didn't look as good
even though it felt right so like could
you put your arm here or can you do did
they have to sort of like oh hey I know
this seems like you're stupid and really
awkward but this looks better when you
do this I
actually in not to like to my own horn
but like on a regular basis directors
and sometimes even the cast will that's
the thing I'm complemented most on it's
just like man you really know how to
move your body I really think it's my
dad's background so and honestly like
what a director somebody comes in to
show me do something I usually have a
thought like do that again they usually
look pretty awkward it's one thing I'm
pretty good grass bums like I'm supposed
to look with a lot of that's good
there's nothing like a good looking
runner you know so I'm gonna just
strides just like that's what they want
for those commercials for like green
screen stuff I'm generally in a fix
stance and like doing my legs really
hard and a lot of the times will do just
the first step and other speedster guest
stars and other people that run the
comment tend to see people do same arm
his leg like when you step forward you
do the same nowhere no but like and then
I always show them what I know like yeah
grant goostin is teaching me how to run
unbelievable he's been running for what
like five years and he just knows huh he
is the flash what's what's the major
difference I should know this because I
didn't realize this I you know when I'm
coming I'm saying I want to talk to you
and interview you I have thought about
it but I certainly haven't thought about
in a while but then I'm like wait a
minute
all right play the flash animated but I
was Wally West you're Barry Allen for an
audience who doesn't know you briefly
like what's the difference Barry was
kind of like a combination of the comics
Barry and Wally because I was a little
younger I wasn't really the age very
usually was and we did a lot of kind of
quirky awkward jokes and I think that
tends to usually fall more in the Wally
realm yes so yeah I don't I mean it's I
I'd be hard for me to say because I
think where we landed with Barry at
least initially was somewhere between
the two and we've kind of grown into
more of a
thirty now I was 23 I think but I did so
like I've grown a little more into a
mature kind of leader version of areum
not quite as awkward on a regular basis
we still have me kind of going there in
less in a while but yeah I mean it's
it'd be hard for me to answer just
because our Barry has never been like
the typical like comics Barry Allen
now it actually doesn't hurt my feelings
at all and I obviously watched you I
don't I don't like watch superhero shows
constantly I mean I was on when it
doesn't mean I'm a huge fan of one I am
I'm a fan I love the world I feel like
I'm part of something that's very you
know popular especially now and I feel
like Smallville definitely was one of
those first shows that spawned all these
great shows like flash and arrow and
Supergirl and all this but well you were
fan were you a real fan and by the way
did you do research like I'm gonna study
all the people who played Barry Allen or
I'm gonna what did you watch Justice
League yeah which my you know the show I
was on DC was it called [ __ ] like they
were it was before digital obviously
when I was still a kid and it wasn't
yeah I didn't know where to get comics
my parents didn't know where to get me
comics but I was a big fan of
Christopher Reeve in that whole
franchise but and when I started doing
flash or when I was cast as flash the
research I initially dove into it's like
reading comics because I hadn't done
that so I got like comiXology was new 52
was brand new at the time so I was
reading like all those and I still
resist the comic sometimes now again our
show is like kind of its own things so
it's you know you were on a CW show for
years and it's CW is very much at
something - so where it's just its own
tone and version of the character I
landed Lex Luthor at 26 years old you
landed Barry Allen flash at 23 now I
certainly wasn't mature enough to carry
a show at 23 let alone 26 let alone
maybe just recently I'm able to maybe do
that so when you first find out you know
I'm gonna play this character first
of all you like I much rather play
Superman or are there other characters
that you'd rather play because it's
probably true
flash is probably not top two or three
on your list I mean high school was a
big flash fan but about why Superman was
you know so much better the flash for
sure wasn't wouldn't have been like but
I clearly can pick a superhero at the
time I mean he's grown into being one of
my probably up there with Superman now
just because I'm so emotionally attached
to the character now but I don't think I
also was you know at the time like I'd
rather play Superman or Batman because
I'm not I never even thought I'd be any
superhero right necessarily like you
know is that the reality we don't like
anyone who would ever thought like
honestly I never thought that I'd be Lex
Luthor let alone anything right so I
mean I'm sure like it look you were a
talented guy you did Broadway tour
you've acted your whole life you've done
all these things you've had early
success but if somebody would have said
to you when you were even 23 before you
ever got the the script or even in an 8
as an 18 year old boy a little boy hey
you know you're gonna be the flash you'd
be like yeah can you say that I was like
I'm not gonna get it and I get a lot of
audition anxiety and you know if I don't
want to waste my time or their time the
breakdown even was like 20 mid 20s to
early 30s or mid 20s to early to mid 30s
and again I was like 23 and looked like
I was 19 maybe and I didn't want to go
to the audition at all because I thought
it was so irrational you know that's
exactly with me I was like there's no
way I'm playing Lex Luthor no one's
gonna cast this guy I'm a dummy I'm not
a joke I'm kind of a joke
I mean let them look at me yeah my
friends even said that they're like dude
no and then you know what you know what
you know what happened grant weave
zoned in man we turned that we turned
the volume on oh man he did you're right
yeah he did our pilot and he was in my
second audition I believe and he called
me after he had seen my tape my initial
issue with David Rapoport casting
director and really early on nutter was
like here I want you to get this you're
gonna get this and that from then on out
I was like you know tunnel vision honed
in on on getting it because he had this
belief in me that else and it made me
have belief in myself but like you
already had some chops you were still
young but at least do you think without
that theater background you'd ever be
able to make it through this no no I
mean I I still to this day I mean I I
don't ever like even take my sides to
set rarely I'm very like obsessed with
like the process of like getting the
scenes down and that's definitely my
theater background I mean III really
drill not just like memorizing it but
the scene work and it's not you know
hopefully I do much more challenging
stuff throughout my career it's not like
it's the nothing gets the writers they
do an amazing job but it's not like it's
the most in-depth like emotional actor
work on a regular basis but I take it
really really really seriously and
really prepared I did to him but it's
almost too much like III did I want to
be too good almost I want to let you I
don't wanna I worked so I worked so hard
that I thought I'm like most people
don't do this a kid does anybody work
this hard and that's obviously silly to
think that but I you know it was
torturous actually especially in the
first seasons like just trying to prove
everybody like I have to prove myself
and do you feel like you just want to
know these lines inside out you want to
just be able to go on set and like it's
a play and let's go taking a little
pressure off myself not taking it as
seriously at times I mean I've never let
up on the work but I've always been
really hard on myself and I still AM
but I yeah I mean I put way too much
pressure on myself early on and got in
my way a lot
shows am i you know in the work like how
like welled up I was and how focused I
was on getting it right you know it gets
in your way for sure do you do anything
before you're doing your lines is there
something like you know I remember Jesse
Eisenberg I was doing this movie that no
one saw called cursed Wes Craven and I
remember every take he would jump up and
down and and spin himself around right
before action and I would do there were
certain things I would do to get if I
had a certain scene but he was doing
this like just all the time and like it
was it was way of doing and I'm like hey
whatever it takes do you have a I don't
know if it's a tick if it's a because I
developed ticks from doing [ __ ] kind of
working myself up is there something you
do you're just kind of zoned and relaxed
and let's go really anxious or stressed
about a really tough scene or emotional
scene but I really want to get right
like I like you said I mean I still
sometimes will have that feeling of like
really wanting to prove myself to just
like the crew like the people on set
they're actually there watching like I
really find myself thinking about it
what's the audience gonna think about
this I'm thinking about the Pens they're
watching yeah yes the inner background I
think yes it's almost like like instant
gratification that instant response like
I remember JD does JD you know JD great
JD I remember just like I remember one
episode early on he just goes hey man
I've had really good man alright gave me
a thumbs up I just wanted that thumbs up
all the time and what I didn't think
they'd realize how much that means to me
come up comes up to me after Cedars yeah
crush that like I mean it means the
world does right they don't think they
think oh they don't want to hear I think
they're thinking they don't want to hear
from the grip that they're good we do oh
I carry it with me for I mean forever
like I usually come over tell my wife
about like y'all like still like buzzing
oh my
see Neil the grubach come up to me
afterwards you don't care about II W
writing an interview saying grant
crushed it you want Neil you want that's
I'm exactly the same way yeah I feel
that same way whenever I'm on the set I
always want to know people's names very
quickly I always want it to be like a
family because I think it's for me it's
safety like I feel like if I trust them
and I could fail in front of them and
they could just pick me up and I can't
be there for them that there's something
I don't know if it's a good a good thing
it's just kind of what I do that I just
I want to feel safe when I'm doing my
work that I know people are rooting for
me around me theatre do shows like
acting class in high school in college
and it's like that's what the
relationship that I had with my acting
classes you know it's like you need to
be feel safe enough to fail and that
you're gonna receive constructive
criticism and we're gonna Pat each other
on the back and we're gonna learn from
each other and obviously like a fool out
physical of me give me constructive
criticism about my scene but you do want
it to feel like a safe place Emily I can
try whatever and and look stupid and
then get it right on the next day
why did you know it was gonna be huge
did you see the pilot go okay this I'm
gonna be doing this for a while I mean I
hate to say that like because I had
never even done a pilot and I now know
like how unlikely it is for pilots to go
too serious even but I maybe it was
really it was really naive like I you
know I was cast on arrow first it was I
did two episodes of arrow and I was
supposed to do a third episode of arrow
that was going to be a back to a pilot
but the character was received so well
they decided to do a standalone and I
knew from then I was like what we'll get
serious just cuz it's the flash and it
like I never thought like it was never
about me it was just about like I'm so
lucky that I landed this and there's no
way the flash phone at least get a
season one you know we're coming off the
heels of arrow and I mean maybe it was
naive of me but I just
I thought at least you know three to
five seasons felt like a given just
because it was such an iconic character
and I was for sure it had myself but I
mean in the meeting TomKat Anand and
being a big fan of Jesse L Martin before
we all came in I mean David Nutter
called me to tell me Jesse was doing
because he knew what a big disco theater
nerd I am right and freaked out and
animator I mean I she's done all kinds
of things but like specifically I
remember when I was younger like earning
sky-high and this cast is like see yeah
I have faith really early on that it was
gonna be fine showing me around for a
while you know I could always tell who's
had a good upbringing in terms of like
close with their parents or you know
we're loved were supported were parents
were proud I could just tell I just know
these things I could tell with you that
you had a good upbringing am I wrong no
we had a great family in general I'm
still close with both my siblings I
talked to my dad not as much as I talk
to my mom but I talked about I'm super
supportive proud of you love you
whatever you can is word comes to me in
my career and this journey didn't finish
college first of all was getting a BFA
in musical theater which is like not a
real thing that's gonna help you in the
world and they were very supportive of
that it was an expensive school at Elon
University which is not suitable a
little b fa a--
you on it was an amazing training and
i'd recommend anyone go down that path
if they you know want to do theater be
an actor at all but then i dropped out
to do with the tour of West Side Story
in probably tour of West Side Story and
like had support from both my parents to
do so and it's led me here so the most
beautiful sound I have I was a jet side
when you're a jet you're a jet all the
way from your first cigarette to your
last dying day what the bad sorry I love
musical theatre as well and you know I
read somewhere where you said you know
you always want to do Broadway and then
maybe TV and film and it sort of been
you know except for that you did the
Broadway tour but you've sort of
which positions it's sort of like TV and
film and career but you always want to
end up on Broadway
yeah for sure I doing my whole life was
theater from like I started doing it at
10:00 and at like 14 it was like
exclusively like my only hobby and what
I did outside of school and then yeah my
whole life was just about musical
theater and around like 1819 I knew that
like acting was kind of more
specifically been for what I was best at
or wanted to follow that path and like
huge I suck huge Ackman and the Boy From
Oz when he used to not on Broadway and I
knew that he was like the he was a movie
star essentially already and I I thought
like oh do my theater path find my way
in the film and once I get like big film
jobs I can just go back and do theater
like Hugh Jackman I mean and somehow is
lucky enough to kind of be on that track
now hopefully now like theater can be
waiting for me when Flash's over well I
mean it sounds like that I mean it
sounds ridiculous either way you put
become a movie star that I'll do theater
and then you know I mean no it's it
sounds like it's absolutely that's I
think you have to have the mentality of
like this is what I'm gonna do and
people say yeah these are the odds and
this is this I I don't know how many
times people said dude come on there's
so many great actors out there I do you
don't understand it's like no I'm gonna
do it it's something you just know and
that success doesn't mean I'm gonna be
this and I'm gonna it's just that I know
I know innately that this is what I'm
supposed to do not should I do this I
don't know I like it it's cool there's
more of like still friendly friends with
and has had a lot of success it almost
like he was frustrated with me like I
was almost getting under his skin that
like cuz I'm not a cocky like
overconfident person by any means I
actually went very and secured a lot of
time and beat myself very self-loathing
fictive but like you said like I mean I
like why would I be doing this if I
didn't think like oh yeah I'm gonna be
on Broadway oh yeah I'm gonna write be
able to do this like why would I be
why would I been doing this if I didn't
believe that
I'll have success yeah that's what I
understand I think there's some people
that you know I have friends that just
like I know I just want to do this
should I do this I don't if you're
saying should I or I don't then there's
there's no there's only there's those
people I want to be a doctor I want to
save in people this is what I want to do
there's not like I don't know should I
be a doctor or should I be I said you
get to a point where like I know what
I'm destined to be whether it's doing
theatre in a small town and not making
any money or becoming a movie star or
whatever this is what I want to do doing
regional theater difference like states
and cities all the time and like knowing
that I was following my passion I
definitely pictured that life sometimes
too as the the least successful version
of what I wanted to do and I was fine
with that this episode of inside of you
is brought to you by magic spoon as a
kid how often do we all eat crappy
cereals
I mean delicious maybe but how bad was
it for you how bad were these cereals
you eat them and you have a sugar rush
and then you spike down and and and our
parents just let us keep eating it were
they thinking imagine you could have a
cereal that is actually healthy for you
that tastes good
see that's something we never
experienced it was like taste great
awful for you
but no not anymore my good friends at
magic spoon magic spoon they have these
great tasting cereals cocoa fruity
frosted blueberry now you can get this
stuff with zero sugar twelve grams of
protein and only three net grams of
carbs in each serving which means you
can you can have this it tastes amazing
honestly it's it's too good to be true
keto friendly gluten free grain free soy
free low carb and GMO free you're
calling Monday magic spoon sorry I
jumped into an impression go to magic
spoon calm slash I owe you to grab a
variety pack
and try it today and be sure to use your
promo code IOU at checkout to get free
shipping and Magic spoon is so confident
in their product so Mon it's backed with
a hundred percent happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason I'll
refund your money no questions asked
all right magic spoon com / IOU use the
code IOU for free shipping we thank
magic spoon for sponsoring the podcast
and thank you for the free cereal magic
spoon delicious you know I support this
theater Public Theatre of Kentucky ptk
and you know they always have problems
and you know keeping the theater alive
is not easy the arts and you know I
tried to be a part of that and you know
and I try to help raise money and on the
board or whatever and I always think is
that you know the ptk Public Theater of
Kentucky is right where I went to school
and it's right there and you know they
have a museum there and they had the Lex
Luthor coat there I donated all that
it's a museum and I'm always like god I
want to go back one day and do a play
just keeps getting further and further
away I did so many plays in college and
I remember the camaraderie that the
feeling right before you go on and
putting on the makeup and going over
lines and doing the stupid tongue
twisters and getting it I always used to
get the stage like an hour early because
it just nerves and dick walk the my part
where I'm going and this is what I'm
gonna say this and sitting in a corner
and there is something freaking cool
about that there is something that you
can't really it's you can't describe it
right yeah this is my 14 year old dog
and you can hang out with us stretching
involved but I was there probably two to
three hours before the shower to - if
your rituals and your routine and yes no
it's okay
yeah no theatre I just I miss that
process for sure I mean there's nothing
in TV is
the process of you know the rehearsal
process for a show or the live
experience or actually putting on the
show
there's nothing similar about yeah you
know it's funny I see your parallel of
light and that our parallel because I'm
a lot older than you won't um I guess
some 17 years older than you I could
have had you if you think about it I
don't want to think about it but you
know you think about the parallels of
like going doing theater going through
college and you know I thought it like
you know I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
married I'm gonna have a kid I'm gonna
do this and you know I'm 47 I'm still
well I'm single and I've done all these
things but it seems like you've done so
much so early Broadway tour you know you
did the Glee thing which was really cool
and then BOOM catapulted here you are
the flash and and you're married now you
might have a kid who knows right okay
yeah you might you have a dog it seems
like you have a hat it seems like you've
got your [ __ ] together unless I'm
missing something is there something
that you're just is there something that
you're still you know people say content
are you content or I don't think not you
know if I'll ever be content I know how
I'm very aware especially in certain
moments how lucky I am how differently
things could have gone up until this
point but you know I also like there's
plenty of when it comes to my career or
like there's plenty of things that I
feel like I've missed out on them you
know what have you missed out on what
have you missed out on like I mean
during the flash and be not said it like
Mike it's been so amazing but what were
seven years in now in Ward six we
finished six years and the past four hey
this is now I have had a hiatus project
that has fallen through because of flash
so I feel like there's a lot of other
opportunities out there that have kind
of got like film and stage that have
gone away because of schedule conflicts
you know so you just can't have
everything it's been all flash for six
years which I know you know all too well
yeah but I think that you know
if you look back right now I definitely
don't have I mean I'm sure people say I
don't have regrets
in fact my uncle got tattooed no regrets
in like [ __ ] that's a lot I don't think
I don't think you know what I under that
you should put like a caption like I'm
not entirely true you know I would never
trade off where I'm at right now to be
somewhere else in my life or in my
career I mean I have like I think one
thing I really struggle with we were my
wife talking about it recently I mean my
mom had the conversation all the time
she's the one I have impostor syndrome
for sure like I don't think I ever
deserve anything that I get or that like
I not you know worthy or I didn't work
hard enough for it or someone else
worked harder was more talented so like
that's something I struggle with all the
time you know just being like okay with
where I'm at and feel like I worked I
deserve it and earned it but like I
think that's one thing that really makes
me feel lucky all the time is I don't
know how I got to where I'm at like
almost ever like even when I was in West
Side you know it should have been a
junior in college at the time and all my
friends still work and I was living all
of our dreams and like doing the broader
tour West Side Story like every day I
mean and I was kind of every step of the
way it's not like that I can tell you
why is that that's the thing it's hard
because when people's perception of you
is obviously different from the
perception you have of yourself
obviously you know I'm talented this and
that but like I look at you know Mike
good-looking guy he's really talented
but all that aside the best trait about
you from just knowing you and I think
which is the most important with anybody
is who they are as a person people see
that and if it translates they want to
be around you they they light your you
know you're very likable that's I mean
that's that's a huge thing I always tell
the story of uh James Gunn told me the
story and he directed guardians of
galaxy and so gardenias galaxy to Kurt
Russell they Kurt Russell was telling
the story about escape from New York and
the director John Carpenter was like you
know
I don't know they just want me to make
the character of Snake Plissken more
likeable that Caruso plays he goes why
I'm likeable I'm just a likeable guy
and I think that's true and so I think
that's kind of like isn't your have you
ever had those moments you're like I
don't know the berry seems kind of like
a dick right now too much of like a like
no so you can relate today but you're
innately a likable dude I'm sure you
could play a dick and a weirdo you could
put an eye patch on and kill somebody in
a movie and people like that guy's an
[ __ ] but there's something innately
likable about you and I think it's
humble for you to say that you know you
know do I deserve this there's a lot of
other actors I've done that some my
whole problem is I never fit in I never
felt like I fit in I feel uncomfortable
around a lot of celebrities I put on an
air of like look at me I'm confident I'm
you know and I could turn that on but
but the reality is is I'm always kind of
going because you want to be liked you
want to be accept and that's I've talked
about that do you have you ever dealt
with a you know anxiety in your life any
kind of depression or any kind of
probably four or five I've dealt with
like anxiety depression like I've had
really weird anxious type dreams that's
like a really young kid and I mean it's
in I don't want to get too into it but
we before we got married we started
doing couples therapy just to like you
know be ready for marriage before there
was really nothing going on in the
marriage and then all kinds of things
for both of us starts like come to the
surface and this good presence a couple
in like as individuals and it all kinds
of I mean I was I knew I had always
dealt with anxiety but putting like you
know getting pinpointed ideas about
where things started and why you were
feeling that way anxieties ever-present
in my life for sure well you saw what
happened with with Stephen you know I
talked about it many times and I thought
that was so brave and like I think
nowadays you could sort of talk about
that thing especially in the show it
just it without a doubt I didn't know
this was going to happen but it helps
it just helps people there
oh my god this guy's so successful he
said and he deals with anxiety how does
he deal with it and it's just like you
know you're not saying this is the
answer to fix your anxiety this is like
this is what I do to help me so when you
say hey I went to couples therapy
because I wanted to be a better husband
I wanted to or I want to be a better
husband I want to be a better man I want
to be better on this and I think just
talking about your [ __ ] with someone who
could be objective and someone who could
just it's just how could it not help if
someone's professional obviously what's
the thing that's the most the biggest
thing in therapy that you found that you
sort of heard acknowledged embraced
worked on it and you're like wow that
helped me exponentially I mean just in
my relationship and I'm still working on
it and it in moments it it helps in
another moment I like forget think about
it but like I'm not always as good at
just like really really listening and
hearing what's going on with my wife
because she's more level-headed than me
and more calm and less stressed outs and
I'm always talking about what's what I'm
stressed about or like and I just think
like if she's got something going on
she'll share that with me but you know
we're different and she needs me to like
talk to her and like ask her what's up
and really listening here at work I'm
thinking like well she'll offer it up if
she wants because that's what I'm doing
constantly like I can't ever shut up and
she just isn't that way so in our
relationship that's been huge and it's
something that I'll probably be working
until the day I die okay that right
there
is [ __ ] profound because you know if
it doesn't help anybody else it helped
me just now because I am like this - I
don't know if it's because you know I'm
it sometimes we're selfish we're this
we're actors we're [ __ ] we're in our
head I don't think of a million things I
got a BD and so we're constantly open
about everything that's going on where
most people aren't so we that way but
she's just if she's not you know we're
different we assumes they're fine but
but we need to stop for a moment and go
alright I need to [ __ ] off for just a
minute
and how are you seriously because I'm a
self-indulgent prick yeah I don't think
I don't ever think like oh I'm a selfish
person or like I'm all up in my own
feelings because like I am constantly
also worried about her and other people
and what's going on in the world and
it's not like I'm just thinking about me
and my problems for like my anxiety is
like kind of forefront of like
everything including our relationship
instead of like I said finding out what
her anxieties or what is she thinking
about what is she feeling right so
something I'm definitely dude it's
awesome I think that that's sound it
wasn't an advice you get but it's I
guess inadvertently it is it's like you
know listening it's hard it's like
sometimes just to take a minute and go I
want to say a million things right now
because it's so and just not saying
anything and just going talk to me just
tell me everything you're thinking it's
an exercise about getting things right
and then sometimes I think like there's
no way anyone around me cares as much
about getting it right as I do so then I
start to project that and I've got like
especially earlier on I used to you know
I'm I don't I'm not a dick but like I
can get stressed out and like be a dick
in moments because I really care about
getting it right and I think other
people don't and I think I've come a
long way in my flash journey of knowing
where he's dealing with our own [ __ ]
first of all we're all stressed about
the work in our own way and trying to
keep my [ __ ] to myself a little bit and
be there for other people a little bit
more instead of assuming like they're
not feeling what I'm feeling you know
this is fun jamming it's easy right you
have a good time yeah I like this you
know it's funny because I tried to get
you on a long time ago and you were in
Coober and I got [ __ ] pestering and
now I'm the guy who's pester I'm gonna
do an interview I used to be the actor I
thought that but like I think we touched
on this when we were talking in email
it's like I generally I don't have the
excuse right now that I might work but
like I'm always like I say no to every
because the work is so constant and I
just want to stay focused on it and do
it to the best of my ability so like I
rarely do even like that's just podcast
like you interviewed sure appearances I
don't do all the conventions like I just
don't do a lot of extra stuff outside of
the work in Vancouver did you think in
the beginning they were sort of like
young kid will take advantage of home
interviews this this this because
eventually you probably stepped up going
all right I think I could say something
now you know what no no no no I sleep in
I let it stress me out Lauren then still
said no like season stuff it was really
cool I go into New York a lot for a lot
like more than I do now their first
couple seasons and was completely stoked
about it because like my brother lives
there a lot of my best friends live
there and it's you know it's cool to do
like you know it was Kelly and Michael
at the time like the live with Kelly and
Michael and like Good Morning America
that kind of things cool I haven't done
a lot of it I did like Seth Meyers I
think one year and like it's you know it
was really cool like you see those shows
and the that's like a I feel like thing
where you're like all I've made it so
it's not like I don't think it's cooler
I don't want to do it but I really do
care more about making sure I'm prepared
for my scenes when I show up on set and
if I feel like that's gonna take away
from that and it's not hard for me to
say you know no no I don't I don't have
time for that it's not [ __ ] it's
just like I really don't have time to
fight in New York this week Jimmy's got
a huge week next week I need to stay
here get ready yeah you do all the
crossovers and [ __ ] and I've talked to
Stephen y'all about this and I'm like
and Daniella III I don't know it was
hard enough to doing one ship when
you're just doing all these kameen pow I
mean you probably think they're cool
when you see them but shooting them
probably isn't that much fun
I'm guessing it's interesting cuz it's
like the idea of them is like not fun at
all like you like I feel like some
people might say the opposite but for me
like thinking about doing them you're
just like I don't want to do it this
year like it's so like you said it's so
hard it's
so hard to make one episode of
television for eight days and we're
making three to four episodes of
television over the course of like three
or four weeks and with production
schedules that just don't make sense and
like there are moments we're like it's
insane and just not humans the type of
conditions and hours that were in but
like I'd be lying if I said it wasn't
like some of the more fun more memorable
moments didn't happen like during those
crossover shoots you dread them a little
bit but then when you're there and it's
like melissa and like brandon brown and
stephen and like we all like are so
different but have all these things
income and we're just like never get to
see each other and you're laughing
constantly yeah it's fun too it's hell
and it's like most fun how many suits do
you have how many flash suits do you
have and do they start to smell after
like a day of we're in that [ __ ] yeah
I'm a bacterial infection here we go
today I think it like right now that I
have I want to say there's probably like
two hero suits and maybe a third that
like we constantly like mess up with
like pick points for harnesses and stuff
but sometimes I only have like two or
one because one gets destroyed and they
all have to pick point in that with a
harness and then like that day they need
like while that's on me they're like
stitching it shut because then we have
hot suits all right it just kind of
depends on like what we get is be honest
what's the one Broadway show right now
that comes to mind that you would love
to do that you'd love for it to be your
first Broadway show when you're able to
do Broadway that one Broadway show that
if that was it I don't know I mean
that's a hard question because there's I
first of all don't get to see allow you
to get to see way more before I was
doing flash right like at any given time
I don't I've seen like nothing
I Darren Criss buddy of mine you know
that I'm sure you know obviously one
like every award you could win like two
years ago for that Prasanna show but he
wasn't Glee with us and and he was great
when I came on Bleus and probably more
than anyone else like knew he was from
the theater world and knew that like I'd
done nothing like helped you understand
what everybody's job was really helped
me feel welcome he was about to do
American Buffalo with Laurence Fishburne
and Sam Rockwell of heavy and I could I
don't think I've ever been as envious as
I was when I saw that announcement I'm
actually like like clearly reading all
kinds of things right that's what I'm so
straight play is I think more now what
I'd love to be doing I got this need to
kill a mockingbird this past season and
I had a couple friends that were in that
I mean that would be another it was with
Ed Harris at the time and like something
like that I can't even do can we do it
mice and men and I'll play Lenny yeah
you're gonna have to gain like 30 pounds
but I could no that's gonna be tough I
try to do beg it goes to my face now
that I have this beer eyes I said you
know screw it I'm growing a beard for a
corn chest so you're growing a beard
you're probably right and you know I
finally I got the e of the email hey
dude I love you your beard looks
terrible I'm always jealous from Steven
grosser dude I think his spirit is
really cool because chin that's the son
of a [ __ ] he's like perfect
you said something you're actually
watching new girl last night it was his
episode you took his shirt off and
you're just like Jesus Christ son of a
[ __ ] I can't get away from this you
said that you said you wouldn't wear you
told Stephen Amell I won't wear a
t-shirt on cam with your I have to wear
a blazer because look at you it's true
it's like I've always been thin I've
always been really buff and then I
always had Tom Welling around me so when
whenever I had to do a scene like I go
you have to give me two months notice so
I could rip out so hard that I kind of
look good yeah I don't even do like you
know we're not a typical show in that
respect
like the lead being like beautiful and
shirtless all the time like I really
early on looks like I did a few I'm not
I'm gonna take my shirt off anymore
That's not me I'm really honestly guard
this quarantine is the most I've worked
out since flash started just because I
have time yeah I'm starting to like work
out I'm cooking for myself
and I like the beard I think you look
good with a beard I'm more stooped
united man inside of you is supported by
better help online counseling boy do we
need that now this is something I think
that every one of my guests including me
and my listeners a lot of them not
saying all of them but you know I think
a lot of people can use this I think
everyone can use this if you're
struggling with stress anxiety
depression you know anything really LGBT
matters grief counseling got sleeping
better help online counseling is for you
you're not alone better help counsellors
specialize in so many issues and you can
connect with your counselor in a safe
and private online environment anything
you share is confidential simply fill
out a questionnaire so they can assess
your needs and get matched with a
counselor that you feel comfortable with
in less than 24 hours you get scheduled
secure video or phone sessions with your
therapist plus exchange unlimited
messages it's easy if for any reason
you're unhappy or you want to consider a
new counselor request a new one there's
no charge at all and we'll make that
happen you can get professional help
when you want it wherever you want it
better help is a truly affordable option
and our listeners get 10% off your first
month with a discount code inside so why
not get started today folks go to better
help calm slash inside that's better h
ELP comm / inside talk to a therapist
online and get help inside of you is
brought to you by sun basket my good
friends at sun basket i'll tell you it's
hard enough you know you're always
ordering food and for me their safety is
very
right you know you want to know that the
people you're ordering from take it as
seriously as you do so what I like about
some basket is their safety they care
about you and your family son basket
facilities have the highest levels of
food and employee safety enforcing
strict adherence to the existing
standard operating procedures increasing
sanitation frequency so I wanted to say
that first before I even start because I
think that's a huge thing it's a big
thing for me so if you get some basket
you know before I even start telling you
about it that you know these people take
care of you
some basket delivers healthy delicious
meals straight to your door and I don't
care who you are you they give you these
great ingredients and it's as easy as it
takes you 15 minutes I could do this in
15 minutes which is pretty incredible
wide range of recipes I like their
salmon the roasted salmon with miso
glazed eggplant delicious black bean to
stop us Diablo with cabbage slaw and
guacamole hoisin steak strip lettuce
cups with pickled daikon and carrots you
can order from any recipes across the
menu they've got gluten-free they've got
paleo they've got anything you really
want delicious recipes for all kinds of
dietary preferences paleo gluten-free
Mediterranean vegetarian it goes on and
on it's just easy and fun it's actually
fun you need you have so much time and
15 minutes to cook a meal it takes that
long to make a sandwich son basket is
what I'm doing I think you should too
you should give it a shot right now some
basket is offering $35 off your order
when you go now to son basket dot-com
slash iou and you enter the promo code I
owe you at checkout sign basket calm
slash IOU enter the promo code I owe you
a check out for 35 bucks off your order
son basket dot-com slash IOU and enter
the promo code I owe you well here's the
surprise was the [ __ ] Stephen Amell
was gonna pop on and he was like you
know his big thing and he's been like I
want to come on can I come on so my gap
yeah so he's gonna probably do an intro
he's gonna do an intro is there anything
you want me to tell him
like is this like the palm spring
effector like what's going on like it's
like too cool it's okay I'm gonna at
school it's like just not I've never
seen him look like Jesus these are some
questions from some fans for my patreon
Mary bee it's called [ __ ] talking with
rose mom they're quick you answer him
quick if you could go back in time with
no worry about the butterfly effect what
historical figure would you like to meet
christopher reeve even though he's not
really a historical figure like a he
that was probably one of my girls I
guess he is kind of but that was what
happened him was just so tragic and I
know he made a whole second life out of
it was able to inspire you know all
kinds of people and do all kinds of
positive things but was just awful and I
was devastated when he passed away so if
I could have known him in his prime and
like even got to work with him or
something I mean that would have been
that would meant a lot to me
you got to work with him as are you're
saying that I just he was on small it
was on Tom had his scene he had his
scenes with Tom but I did get to meet
him and I went to a Christopher Reeve
Foundation event in Puerto Rico and I
got to present him a blanket signed by
the cast at Madison Square Garden for
like a charity hockey game and yeah I
kinda I got teared up man I guess Scott
got emotional I mean I just said hey I I
was on small but I didn't get to work
with you and I'm really bummed about
that but I love you and I've always
loved you and just thank you for being a
true Superman and and it was just
awesome and we just sat there and you
said a few words and yeah talk about
like talk about facing the most adverse
is just facing such horrific
circumstances and then going I'm gonna
keep going and I'm gonna be better and
I'm gonna do more for people and I'm
gonna be a better man than I ever
thought I was yep it's crazy uh Janette
what do you miss most about the
Tidewater area lived in Portsmouth many
many years she did was the most time in
is really different from like Virginia
as a state and I mean it has the beaches
you know it was like big city small city
but and I had a really normal happy life
for the most part growing up and school
area I mean I'm a big tides fan of the
Norfolk Tides we let you go to those two
triple-a team we go those games a lot
just the Governor's School where the
from your high school that I got to go
to growing up was really special is a
really special place and trips to the
beach with friends and just you know
simple life of being a teenager Nikko P
who's your favorite 90s character I mean
you were born in ninety but who's your
favorite killer the one thing you
remember watching going I just I'd let
that the first thing I just popped into
my head I thought it was nice
Zack Morris by the Bell
yeah baby inquiry core what's Corey's
last name from Boy Meets World Matthews
so you watch those shows oh yeah
Swain did you watch Smallville you
didn't it's very fun thanks Superman
family I think because of that I didn't
of course I [ __ ] that Razi what was your
favorite memory so far on the flash
remember one moment we like I kind of
couldn't stop laughing here I cried I
got emotional something where it was
just at that moment that night something
happened and you just feel like or just
whatever there's a specific moment that
I'll never forget I mean honestly the
first thing that came to mind was just
like times with Kavanaugh in general
they're like we can't stop laughing just
like this they get stupider and stupider
as we go but like funnier and funnier
and then we're like we remember for
weeks and like sometimes like when
they're really funny like some of these
crew members that compliment us on
scenes well like come up to us and tell
them that you guys like that's so
gratifying to to hear like that to his
wife like but a specific moment I'll
never forget was the season 1 finale and
shooting the scene to this day as maybe
the best scene I general the show where
Barry goes back he thinks to save his
mom from getting killed by the
reverse-flash and then stopped cuz he
realizes he has to let it happen but
then he gets to have this moment with
her she's dying and Barry's like an
adult and she has the moment of
recognition and knows that it's him and
doesn't understand why but accepts that
it is
had this crazy emotional scene and I
mean I I'll never forget shooting that
scene or the like subsequent hours at
home after we're like I couldn't shake
it like I was in the shower like still
just like hysterically crying with my
mom had died in front of me for real
like it like as an actor was just
something like I still draw from yeah
when you can draw that that is just like
the most powerful thing ever if you
could use an experience to get you
somewhere there's I mean yeah well I
mean I think for the reason I always
still draw from it it's like that
storyline is still present with Barry on
the show so it's like I don't have to
fake I've never lost a parent like I
don't have to fake anything
when I do that storyline because I
really have those visceral like
emotional reactions to thinking about
losing Nora Allen Barry's mom because it
I felt like I experienced it like for
real like it wasn't like something I
read in the script did you uh maybe a
stupid question did you feel like
calling your mom after that I think I
tried talking to her about it I was like
I really felt like I experienced losing
you like it was yeah I mean it was crazy
you know Lisa asks you know you go from
a villainous character like on Glee to a
hero character in the flash I mean
what's what's harder to portray and
which what do you like better you like
playing the hero
or you like mixing it up you're an actor
right it's I also you know loved getting
the opportunity to play this character
that's just like innately I mean has its
flaws but it's just like so good and
like so well-intentioned and he has his
down Falls and falls at times but like
really puts other people before himself
and I've learned a lot you know from
Barry over the years
I love playing Barry so yeah I don't
know I mean it's I I definitely want to
shake things off outside of church and
play other kinds of things but I also
you know I like playing hero rock rocks
what's your favorite musical I mean we
kind of went into that you said play
maybe American Buffalo kind of see but
it's hard for you to kind of the musical
there see my brothers story just because
I did it for a year
yeah it's the only one I've done for
that amount of time but like I've had a
lot of great experiences with musicals
over the years and there's a lot of
things like evenly can't be silly ones
I've never done but always loved and
want to do it's like hairspray like
Eileen Clark didn't hairspray
I got Matthew Morrison I think it's like
what am i early Broadway kind of heroes
that's all I've wanted to climb what
music like in the past and said this is
an equation to me I'm thinking like do
you see you have to you're musical
you're trained what do you sing around
the house like I knew stop I want to
hear it you say any 70s or 80s or 90s I
know and I used to sing way more I think
when I left musical theater and started
doing flash like unlike Melissa like
thing things pop into her head
constantly whatever were working
together she's always seeing obscure
musical theater references and she's not
married to my buddy Chris who was a
musical theater major with me at Elon
University so their whole household is
it's like my wife like wishes she could
sing but cannot sing and knows nothing
about musical theater so it's like I
I've kind of like left it behind me a
lot these past few years but I mean like
seventies or eighties music or 90s or
displaced something if I was just like
music music yeah and I haven't recently
but like I've always loved Jason Mraz
and like I can sing his whole catalogue
like if we're in the car and 20 songs
what's that this song you know what's
the fish song fishing or fishing I don't
[ __ ] know this what's the one jason
morass on the [ __ ] what's the one
song that you just did the it was goes
through your head used to everyone
somewhere I just start singing I'll just
sing it I know all of this songs I mean
I get it you're not going to say sorry
but do you warm up and [ __ ] when you
sing right that's like dance and singing
it's like I never I was always pretty
good at both more dancing than singing
actually but like I hated going about
ballet class I hated go to dance class I
hated stretching and warming up like I
hated doing vocal exercises to get ready
to rebel but when it comes to acting
like I like the preparation and like
that's when I kind of started to realize
at 18 19 20 like there was more where my
passion it was like really focused I'm
like trying to come right out there I
didn't care as much about trying to
become a great dancer I just kind of was
good at it do you get nervous you get
nervous for auditions you get nervous
fraud that auditioning to get really
like in your head does it take you like
I need to take to to get into it not
always usually I like you know what I
mean actually sometimes too like I don't
do them over and over again but like I
get nervous they gave me like comic-con
I can't eat the morning before comic-con
like what I'm really nervous like I
don't eat during the day like it's
really bad like it's one of the reasons
I'm so like anxiety who rules my stomach
hey Tom I've actually just been passed a
few like six months or so that started
to change where I'm like eating more
working out more like my stress levels
are a little lower
but ya know I get really nervous and it
like dictates my appetite for sure I
love it
well dude this has been this has been
incredible I you know I don't want to
talk to you for a while and I know I
heard somebody good things about you
from I mean everybody there wasn't
anybody okay but there's this one person
who's no no no everybody's like you know
this is a normal great guy who works
really hard and is pleasant to work with
I mean you always want to hear like you
know we're humans I'm sure there's times
on set where you yeah but you don't
throw a Christian Bale but do you ever
flip out I mean I pretty much don't do
that anymore but I used to like season 1
season 2 I had in my head to like being
an aunt season 2 season 3 probably being
a number 1 was like part of my job was
to keep the day going into like because
I
the show better than like the guest
director or whatever but like I didn't
have enough respect for guest directors
the first few seasons knowing it like
they had done that's a lot more than I
had done it they knew what they were
doing and yeah I'd gotten into my head
from you know sir partly for myself
partly from other people telling me like
I'm the only person they're gonna listen
to if I tell them like let's move you
know why aren't you shooting where I was
shooting and like I came to realize like
that type of behavior only didn't it
didn't help but it stressed me out more
like I don't want to be that guy yeah
but like I had at times become that guy
and I don't do that kind of [ __ ] anymore
like I know conversations with the
director about things that are going on
but I tend to not publicly declare
things on set anymore
there's something to be said about you
know I think we've all done that we've
all like anywhere doesn't have to be
acting whatever you you know you it's
just a waste of energy it's like this
day what am i saving 10 minutes 20 I'm
probably losing and it's just causing me
grief and stress let's just I'm here to
room let's just film yeah flash was and
then suddenly being the number one was I
think I could have learned watching
other people like that did it the right
way but I don't you know it doesn't help
it's just wasted energy to come in and
like think that you're helping the day
move along by like declaring that like
we need to be moving you're 23 years old
too by the way you know yeah I'm telling
you I don't know what would have
happened if I would have like I mean I
was 26 and thank God I wasn't lead I was
second to Tom but you know but I had
been working for a while I just feel
like I wasn't ready for it to carry a
show and - kudos to you for like being
able to do it especially like the stress
and the anxiety could start really
thinking about these things and that's
also what I've learned now is just stop
thinking about tomorrow you really
honestly it sounds stupid just think
about today right now what do you have
to do
I have to do these lines I have to be as
great as I can and that's it
I don't have to think about these other
days right now because I want to stress
the [ __ ] out of myself all right I think
that's the I think that's probably you
eventually did was just okay I'm here
yeah I realize you know I could be a lot
easier on myself and that's like the
whole production if like I didn't put so
much pressure on myself to feel like my
number-one role like until more than it
actually entail which is just learning
my scenes ending you know most prepared
friendliest person I can be how many
seasons left us a flash one on my
current contract just season seven
that's gonna be a tough one when they
throw money at you and they're like hey
yeah the conversations actually had
started already for potential and then
this stopped so and we don't know when
we're going back and we didn't finish
our last what should have been our last
three episodes two episodes of season
six so and they said no or not I mean we
might do those scripts when we go back
for seven to lead into what we were
gonna film anyway but we don't know when
we're back and I don't know when we're
gonna continue the negotiation talks and
you don't know yeah though there's two
also there's two thoughts two one
well if I do sign on for a season eight
nine you know I'll be fine for quite a
while I have a family blah blah blah
maybe this then I won't have to worry as
much the other is look you know I've
done a show long enough I made some
money and I just want to go do my own
thing so it's kind of that there's for
sure
the thing that makes it I really have
lost like three films and one theatre
opportunity that we're like locked set
ready to go and then those things had to
push like two weeks and my whole hiatus
is two and a half months so like they
had to recast me mmm yeah and that's
hard to deal with that's hard to swallow
and then I had another one this hiatus
and then this happened so like that
movie is not happening obviously so it's
yeah they will remember the frustrating
yeah well remember this to anybody who's
like you know you're you got your
friends you got
whatever but I love my age he's nice and
the guy's the studio everybody's nice
and then but everybody's gonna be like
this is what you want to do this is how
you want because everybody gets money
everybody makes money you just make sure
whatever decision you know how to do
this just make sure you're the decisions
in your gut this is what I want to do
that you guys do so like you know base
that milestone there's also something
incredibly like we man we did that and I
don't know I mean I'm glad too that I
was like locked into the contract that I
was locked into because like we're
talking about those earlier stressful
seasons like if I could have like there
were plenty of crew members that like
walk after season two like I probably
would have also because I was just like
this is too stressful like this is too
hard the hours ridiculous like I would
have just walked to if I wasn't like
locked down and then yeah glad like the
slap you know that bit on the journey
I've been on and I'll ride it as long as
I can probably yeah you got the great
fans I look at the comments I look at
the love a little bit the support that I
go to the cons and you know the fans are
honestly what keeps keeps it all going I
mean without them it is it's just
unbelievable like small look is over ten
years now and it's still I go there and
there's a new resurgence on Hulu and I
meet these kids and it just it just it's
just such an amazing thing it's amazing
thing to have who would have thought and
like you have millions and millions of
fans and you know and I get to be one of
the animated ones look it surprises me
because I was it's just my voice I know
people love it they're like all that but
you're you embody your the your the the
physical and the the your your the look
at my followers I think they like you
better
all right you got a lot more followers
buddy but look I just appreciate all the
fans and today I really appreciate you
for coming on and hopefully when this is
all over one day we could
could hang out you know I love that and
come in and do it like an in person
inside of you - that would be great down
the road hopefully this will clear up
and we won't have to zoom it up what a
got us together yeah so thank you for
allowing me to be inside you my friend
and good luck with the wifey and the dog
the 14 year old key what's the dog's
name yeah James oh dude that's great
oh that's cute I gotta get a tattoo of
mine mine's like 12 or he's getting old
10 years yeah yeah I just love as much
as you can man cuz you know how much
longer do I have it's always like I
hugged him they might get mad at go [ __ ]
you could die any minute I got that's my
cob I shouldn't yeah alright dude I love
you hey thanks so much for this thank
you alright
pretty fantastic Thank You grant for
being so open and you know what he
talked about therapy with his wife and
you know people don't want to talk about
that stuff but I think it's starting to
have my podcast like this pocket other
podcast the mental health thing the it's
you're just gonna get better you're just
gonna feel better yeah these people just
don't want to talk about the stuff and
what happens you think that they're
gonna get better I'm just gonna deal
with it myself I'm gonna ignore my wife
or uh I'm just gonna uh man come on he's
brave and he's awesome for doing that
this is how you how relationships
survive they actually talk about their
issues my parents never talked about
[ __ ] I don't think they went through a
therapist did they I mean obviously
they've been divorced forever big
shout-out to my patrons as I always say
without these folks the show just
wouldn't be wouldn't be as good truly
truly thank you from the bottom of my
heart those who pledge when they don't
have to who give a little extra and by
the way the Patriots they know you get a
lot of stuff I try to respond to you I
try to you know do as much as I can the
YouTube lie was extra bonus footage
inside of
me I'm always working on stuff to make
you guys happy and it's community so if
I don't get back to you right away
within a couple days you know it's a try
but it's it's so fun and check out
patreon and here are the top tier
patrons Nancy D Mary bee Leah s Trish F
CeraVe you love you Kiko Jill e Brian H
Lauren G Nico
my main man Barry I Angelina G Lee Jerry
www Kevin R Emily K Bobby Bobby Bobby
not Bobby but Bob be Robert be bored
Jason W Tiana Andrew see Alison al mark
a Jason D Chris Rodge Rodge Sean W
Joshua D Emily SC JP Rock's raccoon
Samantha M Hamza be Stacey bath Carly t
Vanessa in the sky with Rosie Reem I
just like to say room
Jennifer s Janelle be neil w tabitha 272
kimberly Melissa seed Mike II Mikey
that's cute
Jake M Jake mmm Catherine Catherine M
jackass jackass not jackass Jack s Jack
I love you buddy Carly asked Jude @d r
Amira well I mean I love it though Amira
Chris F and I just want to say boy you
know
thank you for all the letters from some
fans remember you could you could write
in hello at inside of you podcast calm I
eventually get these and I do read them
now I don't read all of them online but
on the podcast but I do read them I
think you know that about me now and by
the way I've been going around and you
doing my due diligence so if you see
little messages or responses online I do
look at those it may take me a long time
but I respond sometimes I respond right
away
Senna's it but I reply and I'm trying to
get other people to listen to the
podcast so I don't know spread the word
guys this one's from Seth I just want to
thank you for the podcast you know what
my brother died when we were kids
he was hit by a car in front of me no
one was watching us I like to think
that's when my life took the course it
took I grew up okay considering my
mother's deeper dive and into depression
drugs and neglect I was raised by my
father that was a better experience in
living with my mother
I grew up feeling very alone and
doubtful of myself I'm just thankful for
your podcast it shows me what makes
other people tick
others went through what helps others
and how they think your name is on a
thing that is going on going to live
forever your name is on a thing people
will talk about forever Seth
I I will just leave it with that I'll
leave it at that Seth you know what I
got from this letter is it's
you know things happen and they're out
of our control and it's how you deal
with them
and you know not to be cliche but you
know you can sink
and by the way no one's gonna look at ya
badly if you do but you could also swim
and you could also
do whatever it takes to be the best you
and lift for your brother and you know
people have bad upbringing xand neglect
and this and that and I think that a
yeah I try to think of it as like you
know obviously we could sit there and
say what we're grateful for and there's
lots of things and if you do that things
are gonna it's gonna help and also
getting help is important but I think if
you put things into perspective like and
remember I'm not a Tama dr. Phil here
I'm just saying what I think that's all
life as far as we know we get one life
that's what we we know we don't know
what that what else there is out there
so if you think about it like that no
matter how bad things get this is it so
if it's it
you're like I hate this I just keep
thinking it will get better
hopefully you have a long life right get
a lot of people live to 70 80 90 who
knows
never know what tomorrow brings you
never know what little golden nugget is
right around the corner
and I think that's what keeps us all
going you know
that tomorrow is better and we just have
to keep looking
for that golden nugget sometimes we have
a golden nugget in front of us who we
don't even know it we don't even realize
it we're not aware of it until it's too
late but I don't know I don't know I'm
saying anymore but this touched man I
guess that's what I'm trying to say Seth
is it touched me and um thank you for
this and I hope you're doing well and I
hope you you found that little golden
nugget and I hope you're doing well
thank you everyone for listening patrons
will be doing it's a YouTube live with
you soon again and thank you for all the
support spread the word if you guys want
to join patreon if you're not check it
out and go to patreon and good inside of
you podcast a big shout out and thanks
to Ryan Taye as my editor and engineer
and my friend friend then engineer and
editor friend and editor and I love you
buddy you're great I appreciate all your
hard work hopefully this thing will blow
up eventually Thank You Bryce roll your
hard work you just bust your ass and do
so much wear so many hats and I just
don't know what else to say you're
amazing Jess I love you we haven't seen
each other a lot because of the self
quarantine a couple times stopping by
and just dropping [ __ ] off at the front
or whatever but thank you for all your
hard work and helping me pursue my
dreams and thanks everybody
make sure you subscribe and send stuff
out since it send a link send a link to
everybody in know and tell everybody
online store inside of you online store
has merch for left in Laurel we got new
t-shirts coming out very soon inside
either they might sell out who knows
they're pretty dope I think you're gonna
love them and yes we got black boots why
do you get black t-shirts yeah we got
black t-shirts Ethan I love you Ethan
big shout outs my friend Alex fat of
that shoe always listens to the podcast
my friend Troy all my friends all my
Patriots all my every
even Uncle Dave who's now listen to the
podcast I love you thank you for
allowing allowing you to be inside of
all of you and until the next week
[Music]